[Music]
three two one action so welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we wanted Nikki tux over me as
I'm trying to sorry hold his leg muscle
try to do a score muscle again but hey
Jamie I missed you thank you thank you
thank you my dish it was the only one
that said it
yeah your eyes were like I was what I
was in love with this I was like I was
admiring the scorpion pose it looked
pretty cool Chinese Kung Fu gold as much
I was thinking about danger boy your boy
boys do it did your boys like this am i
doing it right drop it you don't you
don't do it for you boys thank you boys
okay former gang friends were like dude
you're gonna get a lot of people killed
for that shoes they were messaging me on
all of us going like this mean you know
I mean just doing gang signs but it's
fake game I know I know but they're like
what if some kids do that in the wrong
neighborhood and it's like they don't do
it gets misconstrued as a gay actual
Bethan it's their fault right because if
you're if you're like a non black guy
listening to rap and you go start saying
the n-word all over the place and eat
your ass beat that's kind of your fault
why is that my fault
I used to be cool to do that blood one I
can't remember how to do it I was in a
beach town in Santa Barbara so we were
allowed to do it because there's no
actual place yeah all right so yeah the
reason why we're bringing up danger boys
is because what's happening guys next
Friday we got our screening in Irvine
5:45 p.m. at UC Irvine UC Irvine it's a
big-ass campus so I know a lot of you
guys were doing on to prepare for van is
that sucks
makes yes make sure you go there like
five cuz you got to get parking and then
it's a big walk and protesters you
should show up a little early good yeah
4:30 4:45 this is January 17th by the
way I'm like we said in 2020 2020 open
to the public it's open to everyone well
you got to get tickets though where is
it on campus you have to go to the link
in the description see link in there you
get a description below Lincoln are we
gonna carpool
oh we can cuz I wanna drive an aardvark
it's gonna be a meet-and-greet with Bart
Joe Steve Casey and also Q&A with the
guys so they and other JK people are
coming special girls big names too Big
Jake Kane big JK names the biggest
really is David coming no no he wants to
come see it
we're talking about huge it might be
there but I hope you on the outside cuz
he can't come thank you
he could be outside waiting yeah but
yeah if you guys are planning to come
make sure you get your tickets ASAP
because it will sell out and protestors
you don't need tickets you can just be
outside exactly what David area or even
if you are if you would like to host
your own danger boys screaming make sure
to email book jkf at gmail.com for more
info and you can have your own DBZ
screen danger boys and that is it look
like in your own house oh yeah unless
you want to play like a million bucks
that's a good point
um there are some blind athletes though
that would message their like 13 and are
like hey so my junior high wants to have
you guys come down what you guys come on
down I'll go to prom with you oh there's
some that they're like can you can you
be at my birthday party and I'm like
yeah I don't know if I if I didn't need
money anymore like an almost [ __ ]
rich I would do all that yeah I would go
to every [ __ ] don't be like come to my
birthday party I'll be like [ __ ] yeah
where you at Florida alright I'll fly
over alright now I'll be like the random
35 year old guy a [ __ ] 14 year olds
birthday party
the main town Berlin like how the [ __ ]
do you know my kids and I'm like he told
me to come to his birthday you want to
see the email what the [ __ ] because I
feel guilty like a gift in his balloon
yeah I'm like [ __ ] your kid invited me
what am I supposed to do Oh like this is
his bris
he's an infant I'm like oh that's where
they cut the it's really custom size the
baby
Jewish kids yeah I learned that from
marvelous mrs. maple season three inch
that was real it was good as good season
oh really but would you go to 13 year
olds birthday party hell no I would I
would I would - do you have been wanting
to go to quinceanera recently cuz I
don't I don't like I don't know any 14
year olds anymore I do I do want to go
sit it's part of my culture I haven't
been taking these part of my culture
that I don't miss I miss my but what do
you miss about kinnaras especially
especially the atmosphere because
everyone's just like they're like a
wedding but for teenager exactly well
what's going wedding well know about
them one girl in like the tumble on is
and then they have like like a wedding
and then they have a James go to Mexican
wedding and then I want to go to I can
see you know continued de no four year
old Mexican so I'm asking what's so
special I wanna know hey gee I've never
been to one but I have a lot of opinions
about them ya know I'm in like you get
to see all the kids like running around
and you drink a flat [ __ ] you all you do
is mainly for the adults I feel like
your arguments feel pretty strong
argument so pretty strong Mickey I don't
know to me it's it's like thinking about
having a second wedding and she's
Mexican like you just go to that you're
gonna want to have a second winning okay
you don't want one
yes I do all right well like if you
don't come then it is like a concern
Eric cuz it's just about the car Mexican
girl
30 to 500 on 36 get that you get the
incinerator yeah what's a tumble on a
tumble on what's a tumble on tumble on
is the boys that are like that are like
holding your Amish it like dance dance
of the bunch of boys yeah oh yeah and
it's like don't come you're not invited
to it but there's also that mess which
is like girls like a dame I wonder what
the dumbass in trampoline party I little
jet heard that [ __ ] wait isn't that a
date boot yeah Filipino version yeah
yeah I never got invited one of those
either didn't know no that was like you
don't get it girls yeah why you don't
forget it I was all me on between me and
my brother we were the only Filipino
in the whole city but your your dad side
of the family they didn't have that [ __ ]
no no they're American they did um
what's it called the etiquette thing
with that here etiquette oh my god
chameleon chameleon what of your dad's
balance cool yeah it's like Charm School
like I said charms nobody love bunch a
little she doesn't hear your voice girls
and guys they learn etiquette but it's
not called tars Filipina thing I want to
go to that to do with that called the
military so whatever I want to go to
that okay that we dated that instead of
the Filipino got it all the butler
academy called camellia no quitter you
lost me no no they had to go through it
it sounds like chameleon did you go to
it no but I wanted to because they were
doing it but they always complained
about it but I just wanted to do is like
complain with them story of my life I'm
check pleasing this date okay this was a
date please think if you do that like
you know how to pay the bill like you
know all the attitude I want to learn
that [ __ ]
yeah and you need to learn it medic it's
cool yeah I think it's goin in like
there's like a dance where the dads do
it too and they did yeah the like you go
to a dinner and the dads do all the
etiquette stuff and like I don't know I
wasn't part of it I want to learn how to
be rich that's not part of it this is
more like like when you're yelling at
your girlfriend don't call our [ __ ]
[ __ ] kind of stuff
no no I don't think they teach you that
[ __ ] they teach you like your
binoculars you don't do it in public
maybe that's what the I see I'm trying
to be like foofy-foofy Richie Richie you
know that's what it is that's what I'm
trying to learn the dinnerware sets like
you know like woman yeah like that when
I'm [ __ ] eating with the president of
the Czech Republic right yeah how the
[ __ ] am I supposed to act when I finally
meet me [ __ ] Putin man [ __ ] I don't
know Joe I hope not like that might be
kind of cool
I need to meet Putin actually might be
cool but then well about you're the
queen of England or something that's
different yeah it's different she's got
tattoos so you're still okay you know
what I would do around the credit
English you might be like that's not the
fork you use you [ __ ] Pez know so you
know what I do do the Queen in England I
eat before and then I don't you're gonna
worry about it I know I can't do that
then that's rude to not eat dinner dude
British food sucks
what if she's coming to your house I'll
serve nugs this with the club and folk
right who isn't my bad Jersey here with
the pork you like what are you doing
usually with your hands you [ __ ]
peasant you guys never thought of that
how you gonna act when you're around
[ __ ] royalty cuz I'm like damn man I
got to prepare cuz when that happens I
don't know what I'm gonna do but if
you've got there then you got there
being yourself yeah sure they're just be
oh that's a good answer I was gonna say
we all have class how bored would you be
hanging out with the Queen aim
you guys haven't thought this through
hanging with the Queen of England is
maybe the most boring thing I can
imagine doing I don't there's other
royalty that's cool yeah she's not even
close to my age you don't even know what
she does though if it M&M is not
important I don't know what we talked
about she probably knows how to suck
dick real good
wait why why would she have a husband 50
years exactly she's a player player oh
you think I think there's no King of
England but there's no King England
right so she does not put his dick in
his mouth as well saying so why would
she be good at sucking day Oh Prince
Phillip I just I want it to ask her
everything we can be banned from the UK
from talking all this week queen is
married to a prince yeah cuz she won't
give him the crown and [ __ ] Oh what you
telling me that a [ __ ] powerful ass
[ __ ] you wouldn't want to talk to her
she could Knight you dude I'd be so
pissed and I wonder the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] we got married you're the queen of
England I should be the keel and that's
how this [ __ ] should work
yeah but she's ignired the principal was
her bloodline I got so can't I be the
King too well so how come when the guy
marries the chick she becomes the
[ __ ] Queen well because she gave up
the [ __ ] yeah I like Oh weed none of us
really know I know that's what we do
yeah we have a woman president most men
will never have a woman president like
the first lady or the first man first
lady president it would be first man
that does it is the first man I think
it'd be first man and by the way first
man sounds kind of sick first gentleman
movie came I want to be a first man yeah
wait recently did you guys see Ronny
Chang stand up yes oh it's really good
okay didn't you talk about like the
first woman isn't her first lady or
whatever but when it's a guy first dude
it should be first is it's really good
remember that part it's a really good
standard Oh bill Bert come over right
after what did he say it should be first
dude I remember he's pretty good it was
funny and I'm not a comedian so I can't
regurgitate I would love to be because
if you are the first first man you go
down in history as the first [ __ ] in
America for sure really
and you can't wait I mean everyone's
[ __ ] history books forever
yeah that's immortalizing
was it it didn't start by talking about
Michelle Obama like how she's coming out
with a book or something he's like what
did you do pick out outfits all day long
go to every single school and reach
because she was selling out arenas yeah
I can't wait to be first later something
like that is like sounds like the
chillest job ever you don't have to make
any decisions people don't [ __ ] hate
you you just go people hate the first
lady right now decorate for Christmas
well that's cuz she's a vodka all the
other girls it's millennia but I mean
remember
what about all the other funds in the
harness for knowing a [ __ ] about bar but
I'm close oh yeah Jackie oh yo see but
she's for her time you have to be higher
top for me I think she's still hot I
like exotic women
isn't she dead is she dead yes no no I
mean like by today's standards she's
still pretty late compared to Barbara
Bush what time very much exactly the
shoulder pads around the control yeah
who was the second Bush's wife that one
bill burr was like who the [ __ ] knows
her name look I know cuz a little
Elizabeth Banks played her I only know
all of the first ladies look like [ __ ]
yeah especially you go back on earth
damn and then you want to be the first
man you're gonna look like [ __ ] too no
that's why I'll be different
oh so you don't think you look like [ __ ]
will fit in I do want to fly in the Air
Force one that thing looks pretty cool
Air Force one looks so are you gonna
marry her after she became president or
you gonna before okay someone that's you
better get in those political circles
right now then I guess Elizabeth Warren
would be the closest one right sure to
get a husband dude [ __ ] your fun yeah
they should have a class for how to
fight who's gonna be the first one you
gotta Scout them right now you gotta go
colleges and whoever seeing in political
science you gotta kind of like watch
them you gotta head on tulsi gabbard
[ __ ] might be the closest she knows no
it's not bad she yeah there's only four
percent I think it's it's Warren I think
it's Warren Lauren Warren's the closest
put they're gonna start younger this
look her one that's gonna run in like
2060 or whatever like the golf college
I'm gonna be the first man in the
history why are you always trying to be
a [ __ ] what's wrong with that you
always want to be a [ __ ] because I got
goals and my goals are realistic people
are gonna go I know tourists are you
gonna go past the White House to see you
in a mud hut on the lawn
sometimes the first man puts up his
[ __ ] shorts and [ __ ] make you
fixing but the White House is the brown
house
he puts up a museum exhibit of chicks
with giant [ __ ] and they come
a synthetic common that's my goal
see I strategize wins that are very
likely do you think I'd be President
come on man all the [ __ ] that I say yeah
I mean for office I mean showing up
pretty far yeah but he doesn't stay half
the [ __ ] that I did by the [ __ ]
he says they let you do it yeah and he
said it in secret we say that out of the
open you know that's where we [ __ ] up
yeah too honest I you know what I'm
gonna try though what if what if it
actually works
what if I run for local mayor and then
from there I'm Joe can you make it the
crack addict who was a mayor of like
we're Detroiters dog that's a bear in
Idyllwild hat yeah and I know I all did
so what about like governor I think you
could do mayor but what about Governor
IgE Senator Tovar far as you go what
about Congress man the body Ventura was
a governor oh he was talking about is
you have to say that baby I always say
the but but doesn't it Oh once I get
there though I'm gonna say I stepped
down what would you call it when you go
I don't want to do that resign oh so you
are thrown yeah that's why I want to be
first mad cuz I don't want to [ __ ]
work are you crazy
so you want to be useless [ __ ] like read
children's book during my elementary
school your prints that's that's not
useless that's actually very enriching
I think it's useless it gets erased I
see I hate the show cuz I do [ __ ]
fits like that and then that's gonna
ruin me later
well I'm gonna run for president yeah
they're gonna use that sound buy it
it's [ __ ] you show well know the
context but then nobody cares about the
context anymore I want to be like where
people are planting trees and I have a
[ __ ] ribbon and I'm coming in with
massive scissors you've done that
several times
but I want to do that it's a full-time
job so become mayor yeah and I want to
meet with other useless [ __ ]
political rules around the world of that
might be the mascot of the world of
ribbon-cutting so you get invited to
every single one to be man commissioner
cuz nobody goes oh well laughs it's a
thing oh I don't know yeah you do bunch
of [ __ ] in the municipalities what about
all the other useless political people
that go around the world and talk to
each other like they're not really a
mess they go to the UN y'all do that
[ __ ] yeah becoming UN there could be a
socialite they really don't do anything
[ __ ] what if you just play pranks and
you put like dish detergent right
outside the elevator and then walk out
of the White House pretty good sounds
like you know get me a jail just play
dish soap all nations prankster that's
time nation's first assault you part you
put whoopee cushions and every single
chair in Congress harmless I'll sit down
the all fart I like that's pretty fun I
like that that's tight
Secret Service has to constantly check
oh yeah you know what sucks about that
those the microphones wouldn't pick up
the fork sound oh if it happened during
say you know what do you do what do you
think they translate it back there when
someone farts there's like a Russian far
Spanish bar I heard Australian farts go
the opposite direction Oh fine works no
they go how useless we are in society
wait wait why is there a we actually
very important in culture so it's humor
from the [ __ ] that we do this is some
fun [ __ ] work it's not a real job so
what very real love you'll never work a
day in your life oh my god don't please
don't be one of those people we do such
[ __ ] God's work here yeah definitely
do yeah we do we save people from
depression here that's what they say
yeah I know I'm not writing the story oh
[ __ ] man I just [ __ ] put it I do this
for me that's what it really is well
handled yeah Ricky Gervais zhing it we
tried to end on a pause
check it away I do this for me people
say it ain't you made my day and I'm not
I do it for me [ __ ] exactly what you
gotta say it when you hug them at the
meet and greet you sir you saved me from
[ __ ] killing myself and I'm like nah
dawg I saved myself from killing myself
peace
[Music]
[Music]